are you looking beauty it is that's a
big cow as well that's not even that's
not a large cow that's a an extremely
large cow how has that happened the only
guys working at spire only ever let's
like to school kids in at once how it
was the rule for cows just one cow at a
time at Spa
[Music]
hey everyone what's up it's Tom Holland
and this is what happens next with lad
Bible that looks like a good idea oh my
I'm hoping that snake turns around and
bites him what's he doing dragging that
snake leave it be man just let us live
the rough you have to be an idiot to get
killed by a Python I'm sorry to anyone
who's got killed by a Python but you
have to be a proper idiot
they're not poisonous they're not quick
you literally have to be lying still for
a Python to kill you so this man I hope
it gets him it turns out that the snake
tail is attached to a person well then
that would be a good reason to pull on
the pipe that would actually be if he's
trying to save another human being fair
enough be the snake angrily launches at
the man I hope so
see the snake is eating a kangaroo I'm
conflicted there because I do like
kangaroos but then it is the circle of
life and we shouldn't be interfering
with the circle of life that would be
wrong and why imagine if David
Attenborough saved the zebra every time
then the Lions would die right
please bite him please buy him oh yeah
serves you right mate they look either
on Safari you're not supposed to touch
the animal I like how he has a rag
around the end of the snake like that's
the dangerous part idiot Samuel Wayans
did I ish
No oh I think I know what's gonna happen
here
a cat sits on a broken Xbox looking
extremely guilty the guy opens the door
to reveal that his brother has piled up
20 dirty plates and out is perched on
top of the Wardrobe and flies into his
face well none of those were the ones I
thought it was gonna be I thought you
might catch his brother doing something
he shouldn't be doing or should be doing
it's up for debate we don't know he does
look like an xbox kind of guy I'm gonna
go with xbox a that would have oh my god
head league was in his room man now that
was a barn ouch
I thought she said I got the drains dog
poo
woman sneezes is causing snot to cover
the camera that would be amazing
a pigeon flies into the woman's face
that would be equally as amazing a
spider cause out from her fall slash oh
my god I hope it's C no way what would
you do how did you let that happen how
much your cheeping drinking just got
home for its own
what's she doing her woman gets lifted
into the bin a squirrel leaps out from
inside the bin I think that's what's
gonna happen a cloud of smoke puffs out
from the bin well we've seen the bit
open it's got me the squirrel alright
let's have a look I hope there's a
squirrel in there and she fries it yeah
we had squirrels once in my roof at my
parents house and we didn't save them
but we we would trap them in these traps
and then we would take them to Richmond
Park to to free them and squirrels are
scary man when they're in that cage it
was like bouncing around I mentally like
screaming and you know you're holding it
you're trying to like open it and I just
thought the school's gonna run out and
rip my face off and I would never work
again right next she's in Rome okay go
stumbles backwards and into the fountain
a bird poops in her mouth I really hope
it's big a woman steals her coin it in
the mid throat or sees also quite a kind
of good though
imagine if you rock as I've looked
please pull no mouth no way can I see
that again there you go
gee that lady is man that's amazing I
think she makes quite a lot of money you
know let's keep doing this this is so
fun I thought the rugby was at one but
it's actually at three so we've got bags
of time we can finish this down I'm
sorry Titan fury
I'll come on me no you don't know if
dextrous enough for that dog runs onto
the ice and knocks them both over that
would that would make my day a gaggle of
geese hide along the ice both of them
fall through the ice sheet they both
look pretty stupid so I imagine that
they're gonna fall through the ice they
also look English and nowhere in England
does it get cold enough for ice that you
can stand on does it try this have a
look oh you yeah I knew that was gonna
happen
he's so English as Rosa oh [ __ ] what
came out of the spar shop a group of
giant snow monsters load of clowns a
large cow I think a large cow come on
are you little bean see it is that's a
big cow as well that's not even that's
not a large cow that's a an extremely
large cow do you think he's just lost
how is that happened how is it got to
imagine of you with a guy the only guys
working at spire only ever let's like to
school kids in at once you know you're
like only two school kids are allowed in
after school how was the rule for cows
just one cow at a time X bar really well
I did probably more than anyone else has
done yeah everyone else aside I want to
get out of here not me
[Music]